et si la canicule que nous connaissons
ne sortait pas de nulle part sommes-nous
la face aux premiers effets d'un
réchauffement climatique que nous
refusons toujours de regarder en face
c'est la question qui fâche de 7h15 sur
europe 1 et pour y répondre je reçois
jean marc jancovici bonjour bonjour les
deux cofondateurs de cabinet carbone 4
et membre du conseil scientifique de la
fondation hulot pour la nature et
l'homme
sommes-nous jean marc jancovici en train
de courir à notre perte
on courir à notre perte c'est peut-être
un peu fort comme expression par contre
en train de risque et des ennuis
beaucoup plus sérieux que l'idée qu'on
s'en fait là je pense que la réponse est
oui quel ennui et quand c'est ce qu'on
vit en ce moment les ennuis c'est la
canicule je vais me permettre un petit
crochet vous prenez une expérience que
les hommes ont fait trois milliards de
fois qu'il appelle se marier vous prenez
un couple qui se marie aujourd'hui
personne pour autant on est capable de
savoir exactement où ils en seront dans
20 ans alors vous prenez une expérience
que nous n'avons jamais fait qui est
d'appliquer quelques degré d'élévation
de température moyenne à une humanité de
quelques milliards d'êtres humains
bien évidemment personne n'est capable
de prévoir dans le détail tout ce qui
peut nous arriver par contre ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on sort complètement du
cadre des évolutions climatiques
naturelles on va dire parce que pour
donner une référence 5 degrés de
température moyenne c'est ce qui nous
sépare d'une ère glaciaire donc quand la
terre est passé de la dernière glacis 5
degrés ce qui nous sépare de l'ère
glaciaire et là on parle d'une
augmentation déjà de 2 degrés à la fin
de ce siècle oui oui oui donc on est on
parle de quelque chose d'extrêmement
brutal dont il est totalement illusoire
de prétendre voir toutes les
conséquences à l'avant c'est à dire que
c'est un grand saut dans l'inconnu en
fait l'on prend le risque de l'inconnu
l'a absolument c'est un grand saut dans
l'inconnu
il ya deux responsabilités normes des
politiques non quand ségolène royal dit
ministre de l'écologie les négociations
de l'onu sont totalement inadaptée à
l'urgence climatique ça c'était le 1er
juin il ya un mois alors pourquoi nous
jouer dans le même temps la grande
comédie de la coop 21 de la conférence
climat qui est une conférence de l'onu
on nous dit c'est pas le bon outil ça
sert à rien mais allez-y on va se revoir
il faut lui poser la question vous
pensez à vous le climatologue cette
réalité politique je suis là comme oudi
s'attaquer au problème où il n'y a pas
que sur ce problème que l'on peut porter
malheureusement ce genre de commentaire
aussi si on essaye d'être un peu précis
le monde politique a beaucoup de mal à
comprendre les aspects techniques de ce
dossier comme du reste sur beaucoup
d'aspects techniques parce que si je
suis un peu méchant dans le pays dans
lequel nous vivons il ya deux choses que
vous pouvez pas faire en même temps
quand vous êtes dans le monde politique
s'est écrasé vos petits copains pour
arriver au pouvoir et comprendre ce
qu'elles en font des dossiers donc en
général les gens qui arrivent au pouvoir
ils ont des connaissances techniques
très très superficiel sur les dossiers
qu'ils ont besoin de traiter le cas sur
le climat comme c'est le cas sur
beaucoup d'autres choses
donc il ya une responsabilité des
politiques mais il ya aussi une
responsabilité de leurs électeurs
c'est à dire qu'à un moment on a des
politiques qu'on mérite on peut pas dire
je m'occuperai de ce problème pas
pardonné expression quand il fera beau
et puis ensuite dire comment ça c'est un
scandale les politiques sur le cube pas
quand même une prise de conscience de la
part de la classe politique même mondial
d'ailleurs de l'onu de tout ça ou pas il
ya il ya une sensibilisation
on va dire une prise de conscience par
exemple les éléments que je viens de
vous dire c'est à dire que 5 degrés
c'est ce qui nous sépare d'une ère
glaciaire et donc quand on parle de
quelques degrés l'élévation de la
moyenne planétaire on n'est pas en train
de parler d'une plaisanterie ça par
exemple c'est un fait qui est peu connu
rien que ça après les v2 les politiques
ont des mandats cours quand vous êtes en
train de parler de quelque chose qui
porte sur des décennies ça sort du champ
politique enfin je veux dire ils sont
incapables de réfléchir à jean d'angély
longtemps mais pour vous c'est cette
canicule dont on parle depuis depuis
deux trois jours en france
c'est clairement un élément du
réchauffement climatique parce qu'on en
a connu d'autres un dans le temps et on
parlait pas à l'époque de réchauffement
climatique des sorte d'accident comme ça
de de météorologie alors quand vous en
avez un
quelque part vous pouvez rien dire donc
quelqu'un qui gagne au casino vous
n'êtes pas capable de dire s'il a triché
ou s'il a de la chance par contre si
trois fois sur quatre y gagne là vous
commencez à dire il ya un truc qui sort
des statistiques dans no mercy
exactement pareil en ce qui concerne le
réchauffement climatique c'est à
l'envers qu'il faut réfléchir chercher
la température moyenne monte c'est
logique qu'on se met à avoir de plus en
plus souvent des éléments enfin des
événements pardon qui sont chauds par
rapport à ce qu'on avait hélas si on
regarde la moyenne planétaire 2014 et l
année la plus chaude depuis que des
relevés de température et le les cinq
premiers mois de 2000 15 sont les cinq
premiers mois les plus chauds depuis que
des relevés de températures il y avait
tant à 180 c de température
exceptionnelle on la semaine prochaine
on prévoit 30 degrés à la latitude du
groenland par exemple au port du canada
si vous rendez compte ces trucs qui sont
vraiment pas quoi
jean marc jancovici vous est aussi chef
d'entreprise est ce qu économiquement le
problème c'est qu'il n'est pas rentable
de lutter contre le réchauffement
ou est-ce qu'on se trompe parce que les
patrons se trompent là encore alors il
est en fait c'est le problème profond
est assez désagréable à entendre
l'énergie c'est ce qu'a fait la
puissance des nations l'énergie c'est ce
qui permet de mettre les machines au
travail et aujourd'hui ce qui produit
nos chemises notable nos chaises nos
voitures nos bâtiments
ce qu'on mange etc c'est que des
machines donc le fait de renoncer
volontairement à une partie de l'énergie
qu'on utilise parce que dans le monde 80
% de l'énergie qu'on utilise ces pétrole
gaz charbon ça fait du co2 renoncer
volontairement à une partie de l'énergie
qu'on utilise ça revient à abdiquer
délibérément une partie de notre
puissance industrielle qui est celle
qu'on n'a pas cessé de chercher à
renforcer sur les deux derniers siècles
donc c'est un problème économique majeur
ça peut faire des gagnants mais ça peut
ça fera aussi les perdants on fait quoi
là tout de suite qui écrit ce qu'il faut
faire
on a un vrai problème d'arbitrage
temporel on est exactement dans la même
situation que quelqu'un qui doit
aujourd'hui faire des efforts pour
préserver ou sa santé ou sa santé
économique dans 10 ans ou 20 ans sait
jamais une situation qui est très facile
parce que le bénéficient les futures
donc il ya plein de choses à faire
malheureusement aux rares sont celles
pour lesquelles il ya un effort faible
et un bénéfice de court terme
immense ça veut dire qu'il va faire
vraiment faire de gros efforts merci
jean marc jancovici je renvoie nos
auditeurs à votre livre transition
énergétique pour tout ce que les
politiques n'osent pas vous dire publié
chez odile jacob merci bonne journée à
vous aussi